welcome to this video hmm yeah sorry for
my strange reaction somehow I lost
rating points and I don't know why why
maybe I did lose some game what I was
above too far when I last lot oh yeah I
had a bit of a connection issue maybe I
was um I was actually paired and then
disconnected got very strange okay so
back to the chest we have on we have a
Queens gambit accepted a pretty real
line here with knight c6 this actually
something that I had looked at for black
while ago I had to add the preparation
on her game and noticed that my opponent
Grandmaster Cogan was playing this and
he was amazingly successful with this
knight c6 set up here interesting Bishop
to you form hmm
Wow okay so f 3 that's Bishop to d3 the
so this is probably probably nonsense if
I take yeah that's the sage fine can I
take and play Quincy to
okay that's not spend even more time
this is a text c6 and e4 of course my
night Hank so it can take it but then I
take you for not sure what this position
means yeah I don't really know and I'm
still irritated by my raging loss sorry
I need to quickly check this because
otherwise yeah I actually lost lost the
game actually lost the game without
playing due to a connection issue I was
about to far before ok so now I'm
attacking efore nc6 and h4 Hanks I don't
know what you should play now myth no no
I'm a threat not see 6 berth check
this is the actual problem if he takes
h4 i take c 6 yeah sometimes you play a
good move or good concept and you're not
even aware that it is a good concept
okay so he just canceled what to do now
if I take you for okay I can also
retreat the night which is not terrible
ok I want to I want to keep it simple
take it here you take them and now I
place my bishop on c3 and term just say
I'm that I've got I just claim a better
bond structure which is the case with
this week porn cm I could have taken
maybe even but I didn't really want to
look at Bishop before check it so first
cover that ok so long castles actually F
to hang so let's let's do this first I
mean this doesn't really prepare our
castles long but it covers be too so now
I actually threaten to to take and it
cannot really play c5 a place if I I
take Bishop takes Queen e5 friends made
on g7 and the bishop Hank so cannot do
that no it's not bad
hmm
yeah the only annoyances that I cannot
cancel long because of the f 2.8 I mean
maybe I can make a sec out of it but
it's not really a parent term weather
should be great yeah probably a high
move okay I'll play with the King in the
center what whatever brooke's II won't
assume it's on the right on the right
file at least maybe just King it to an F
for something like that
it's really threatening me five are not
really if I can play a for even within
the South pin after you five maybe I'm
threatening f4 now to sort of get a bind
on the center could be a good idea least
it's a playable idea this surprises me
he's not he's never read threatening to
open up the edge farm and I've actually
now threatening to play G five dropping
his queen what it takes with check on g4
I didn't really see that but I can go
here right the g3 well I cannot really
believe that this is any good that he
opens up the position against his old
king but I completely botched up my
calculation yeah I didn't really
appreciate that he takes was check on g4
okay but this still should be good
okay let's just just take it g file
should be should be worth something
especially in connection with the d 45k
grab it and now be three he's got a five
a form yeah but see 67 I I have to do
seven threats if I don't know I cannot
play for now so easily ok and now let's
just prevent the a porn from moving
look a form i F or i can just play
before of course so this is not a
problem yeah I have I can put above
everything protected now and now Luke g1
yeah the look all the way back is a
weakness as well ok so I'm need to play
it in another way
it's going for g5 okay i want i really
need to pawn the best porn going for
that
black4 fits on time yeah I know some
time now I'm not sure what what this is
I'm sure that white has some some edge
but is it winning yeah I probably it
should be winning really i have i have
this ideas like so here i have this
ideas regrouping and he always needs to
look at the pond I mean does this rock
is somewhat tied tied to the apron hmm
yeah probably nothing nothing to defend
him yeah it's just just a better end
game because of the poor weaknesses but
he had a hard time here anyway the sir I
just have the better structure this is
an additional point of attack so it's
difficult not to exchange the bishop so
so we did that but here I'm just too
quick on a4ai can take here and have
this threat we combined attack against
you seven so after something like that
why just has this extra pawn and I mean
this ruckus back in the game I mean on
g3 it's in the game as well but its back
on the queenside again yeah it was a
very reading I mean like to check this
again yeah this was funny
yeah the computer actually are this is
strong yeah the computer has zoom is
just track without mercy in this kind of
concrete positions it wants to play like
that and this is very interesting
actually it detects the bishop protect
the night it has the additional idea of
this check with the rook hanging out on
h1 so something like that cuz that could
happen and then it's a complete mess no
one said got to understand what's what's
what this is Wow yeah okay so no one is
going to play that in the Blitz game so
this is what he actually did again this
is a difficult position but I think
white should have something this is just
just a weak structure I know this as
well but I can attack it with the rooks
and though I think white is better here
alright thanks for watching